armons trésor lé destin tourmenté de la
pologne et de la russie sont liés à
jamais à la douceur de cette vallée
paisible
un aristocrate polonais xavier branowski
fils d'une riche famille de
propriétaires terriens choisi ce château
renaissance après un exil en italie et à
paris
impliqué à 28 ans dans un complot contre
le tsar mon trésor devient sa deuxième
patrie
aujourd'hui ses descendantes marche sur
les pas de leurs ancêtres qui en 1849 à
planter ce jardin de roses roses sont
magnifiés celles ci vont sortir proche
de napoléon iii
le jeune price qui rêve de voir un jour
son pays libre et indépendant
[Musique]
il a eu le coup de foudre pour mon
trésor bien que château était en très
mauvais état
mais il trouvait que la campagne
environnante y très légèrement vallonné
et très verte lui rappelait beaucoup la
pologne et en tant qu'exilé n'avait pu
n'avaient naturellement plus le droit
d'y aller parce que les arts avait dit
que s'il le retrouvait les corbeaux
n'auront passé reste il lui proposait la
libérer et il a toujours été très
reconnaissant à la france de l'avoir si
bien accueilli ce brennus qui se
transforme dès lors en mécène pour mon
trésor maire de la commune pendant dix
ans de 1860 1870
cet entrepreneur progressiste contribuer
à la modernisation du village même dans
les lieux improbables
en témoigne cet édifice néo byzantin
érigé au milieu du cimetière
ce terrain était donné en 1862 par
xavier branis qui pour en faire
justement le cimetière du village et
pour faire construire et bien cette
chapelle c'est plus fade pour abriter
d'abord et bien le la tombe de sa mère
est ensuite sa propre sépulture et celle
de ses descendants
bienvenue frédéric dans notre dernière
demeure dès 1940
cette chapelle devient une plaque
tournante grâce à leurs ancêtres
anna bras niche cas membres d'un réseau
de la résistance à 77 ans elles prêtent
main forte aux maquisards en cachant des
armes
parmi les tombes cette chapelle a suivi
l'histoire un petit peu du village
durant la seconde guerre mondiale est
bien là résistance qui se fait en cash
en profitant de ce lieu pour cacher
quelques armes dans la crypte
aujourd'hui les descendantes des
pratiques ce qu'ils vivent toujours dans
le château parmi les portraits de leurs
ancêtres en bonne place
xavier granit ce qui après avoir fui le
tard il rencontre un vif succès en
france
banquier philanthrope il est à l'origine
de la fondation du crédit foncier
l'humain l'intéressait les gens
l'intéressait et le crédit foncier si je
ne m'abuse avait été créé pour permettre
justement l'accès à la propriété à
toutes les classes sociales
donc c'était déjà quelque chose de très
de très humaniste si on peut dire une
vie bien remplie au service de la france
avec son lot de mystères difficiles à
éclaircir
ah le voilà ici à l'âge mûr je crois
qu'il n'était pas très grand de taille
s'il était grand bon alors là on coupe
[Musique]
elle ne souffre aucune fausse note
cette valse de chopin dédié à la soeur
de xavier bras ni de ski catherine connu
pour sa grande beauté
elle participe à la renommée de cette
famille française la plus polonaise de
touraine c'est fini fille mary mackillop
et merci à la france d'avoir accueilli
la famille aussi généreusement
[Musique]